well it's a pleasure to be here uh back
at Hillsdale College
especially on a day where you named a
chair after my graduate microeconomics
Professor the late great Walter E
Williams
Walter of course would
Walter would tell his students that the
E stood for excellence
and I have no doubt that Hillsdale will
continue a tradition of of excellence in
his name
when it comes to cryptocurrencies and
decentralized finance or or defy
there seems to be a tendency for people
to overstate their case
some proponents of uh cryptocurrencies
they say that they will inevitably
replace the government-issued monies
that everything will eventually be
recorded on a blockchain
that defy will render Banks and other
financial institutions
irrelevant
those unimpressed with crypto in
contrast
they describe it as worthless
as lacking any benefit whatsoever
if you've spent any time interacting in
this space no doubt you have come across
these extreme views they they are
pervasive
and although it's possible
that cryptocurrencies will radically
reshape money and finance such that it
looks nothing like it does today
or
that it all turns out to be worthless
there is a vast range of possibilities
between these two extremes
in that range a cryptocurrency might be
used for for Niche payments it might be
used by those who lack good Alternatives
While most of us carrying on carry on as
as we have before
crypto might enable transactions or
contractual relationships that would
otherwise be too costly to justify it
might make it possible for some to opt
out of traditional payment and financial
services entirely
While others supplement those services
with crypto Alternatives and still
others find no use for crypto at all
crypto need not be and All or Nothing
proposition
and indeed few things in economics are
now today we're going to consider the
prospect of of crypto as parallel
currency
and looking around the the room no doubt
some of us are at very different
starting places some folks here are
perhaps crypto novices While others are
crypto Pros so we're going to start with
the basics what is a cryptocurrency
how does the blockchain technology work
then we'll consider some potential
benefits of cryptocurrencies and finally
we'll assess the extent to which crypto
is likely to be used in the future
so let's get started
a cryptocurrency is a digital asset
designed to function as a medium of
Exchange
a medium through which we exchange the
goods and services we have for the goods
and services we want
a medium of exchange with transactions
processed via distributed Ledger
technology or a blockchain technology
now the first part of this definition
Probably sounds familiar we're used to
making payments with digital assets
your checking account balance is a
digital asset when you swipe your debit
card or initiate an electronic funds
transfer you're making a digital payment
perhaps you have a PayPal account
or maybe you use venmo or squares cash
app if so you are transferring digital
assets that were designed to function as
a medium of Exchange
but those assets
those assets are not cryptocurrencies
why not well payments sent from your
checking account or venmo balance are
not processed using the blockchain
technology
the blockchain technology is what
separates cryptocurrencies from other
digital media of Exchange
now unless you're a nerdy monetary
Economist like me
you probably haven't given much thought
to how payments are processed
no harm there
so let's start with an asset that we're
all familiar with cash
cash is physical
if you buy a dozen donuts with cash I'm
a big fan of buying a dozen donuts if
you buy a dozen donuts with cash
you hand over the cash your cash account
gets debited the merchants cash account
gets credited
and that happens the moment you hand
over that physical asset
this transaction is processed between
you and the merchant without relying on
any trusted third party
we call this a decentralized clearing
mechanism
we call it that because the the
transaction is processed between the two
parties of the transaction you can see
this here in the in the image that I've
shown here these nodes the little
circles they indicate a party to the
transaction the line between those two
nodes indicates a payment that's being
made and you can see that that payment
is going from one node to another
without reference to any other node
these transactions are cleared or
processed via this decentralized payment
mechanism between the two parties of the
transaction that's how decentralized
clearing works
now decentralized clearing works pretty
well for physical assets it does not
work very well for digital assets
think about a photo on your phone
you can transfer that photo to someone
else
without relinquishing ownership of that
photo
you have the photo the person you sent
it to has the photo you both have the
photo
that digital photo would not work very
well as a money
you could make payments with that photo
without actually giving up that that
payment mechanism
not going to work not going to work
traditionally the way we have processed
digital payments is by relying on some
trusted third party to clear the
transaction on our behalf
suppose that instead of using cash you
were to swipe your debit card
in that case your bank debits your
account and credits the Merchant's
account just like we saw with physical
cash but now the bank is ensuring that
you don't send that digital balance more
than once
we call this a centralized clearing
mechanism because the payment passes
through some Central node in that case
the bank so you can see that in this
image here again those little nodes they
indicate the parties to the transaction
but now to pass a a balance from one
party to another that payment has to
pass through some Central node we can
imagine a more complicated system
this works pretty well if if we have uh
two customers of the same bank then that
will just pass through a single node but
we might imagine transactions then
between those Banks and so now we have a
central Clearinghouse between our
Central clearinghouses and so we can
scale this up as much as we would need
to so here in the United States for
example we have the Clearinghouse
interbank payment system and fed wire
that clears Bank payments between Banks
and so that would be a central clearing
mechanism on top of a central clearing
mechanism
I'm sure that you've all heard of
Bitcoin
when Bitcoin was launched in 2009 it
offered a fundamentally new way of
processing payments
it didn't use a decentralized clearing
mechanism
it didn't use a centralized clearing
instead it processes payments using a
distributed payment mechanism
so suppose that you buy some donuts with
with Bitcoin
in that case the network of computers
running the Bitcoin protocol
they update a shared Ledger the Bitcoin
blockchain they update that shared
ledger to reflect the fact that your
account has been debited and the
merchants account has been credited it's
the same thing that happens when you
swipe your debit card or pay with cash
it's just that on the back end that
transaction is processed in a very
different way
instead of relying on the two parties of
the of the transaction to process it
instead of going through some trusted
third party
the Bitcoin protocol and other
cryptocurrencies rely on the network as
a whole to update that shared Ledger
let's dig in a little bit deeper here
we want to see how this blockchain
technology works so when you initiate a
transaction that transaction gets
grouped together with other transactions
to form a block of transactions
then this block of transactions gets
chained to the previous block of
transactions
and so this
shared Ledger or blockchain a chain of
blocks of transactions now reflects the
most recent transactions that have been
made
let's go a little bit deeper how does
this work
well again those transactions are
included in a block
and those running the protocol they
update this Ledger by first taking the
previous block header and running that
block header through a hash function
to produce a an output a new block
header right that's what makes this
chain
and that output has to be an appropriate
block header we'll talk more about that
in a moment
and this process happens again and again
and again chaining this block of
transactions to the previous block of
transactions updating The Ledger by the
network as a whole
to a blockchain a blockchain is it's
just a shared Ledger and a protocol for
updating that ledger
that blockchain technology enables
digital transactions without relying on
some trusted third party
so who gets to update this shared Ledger
or more precisely
how do we determine who gets to update
this shared Ledger
well that depends it depends on the type
of protocol that a particular
cryptocurrency is using
Bitcoin for example uses a proof of work
mechanism
with proof of work producing an
appropriate hash is is difficult now let
me be clear it's not difficult to
produce a hash but with Bitcoin it's
difficult to produce an appropriate hash
and that's because in order for a hash
to be considered appropriate it has to
have a specific number of leading zeros
and so what will happen is that if a if
a minor hashes the block but doesn't get
enough leading zeros he has to try again
and again
and again and again until someone
doesn't merely produce a hash but
produces a hash that has enough leading
zeros
right that hash that output will be
recognized as an appropriate hash of the
block
so what does that mean well that that
means that miners have a random chance
of producing an appropriate hash where
the probability of success depends on
their computing power relative to the
computing power of the network as a
whole
randomizing who hashes a block of
transactions is is crucial for this
blockchain technology to work so long as
I have less than 50 percent uh of less
than a 50 chance of updating this shared
Ledger I won't be able to ensure that an
inappropriate update to The Ledger
persists if I refuse to include your
transaction the next person updating The
Ledger will include it
if I don't have enough power
um
I I can't stop that because I don't have
enough power to cut you out
if I include an unauthorized transaction
the next person updating The Ledger will
just disregard my update I don't have
enough power to ensure that my version
of The Ledger
persists that it's the version of The
Ledger that other people build upon so
the best I can do the best anyone can do
running this protocol is update The
Ledger honestly so that others will
build on my chain and I will secure the
transaction fees and block rewards
associated with my update to The Ledger